das schreibt eine mail an alle
angestellten damit das nächste ableiten
die aber die fertigen da die kugel an
und heroinabhängige ruin deal also
meistens sowie 10 16
der junge den die polizei da
festgenommen hat ist einer von der
familie die machen pro dealer täglich
2000 3000 bis 5000 euro kriminalität
drechsel sogar scheiße
das hat nix
moloch berlin
wir in vielen großstädten des westens
sind harte drogen ein großes problem
abhängige leben nur für die nächste
dosis sie treffen sich im untergrund in
u-bahnhöfen der suchtdruck ist hoch und
der ton dort ist raum
[Musik]
ihre drogenprobleme in den griff kriegen
die araber verschicken die kugeln heroin
abhängig und die machen ebenso wenn
diese kamera gestohlen dann stellen sie
ihren bruder da drei vier tage zeigen
sie behindert dann sind wir dran
bei bild hat eine ausgepackt der weiß
wer hinter dem handel steckt wie die
dealer nach deutschland
wenn er zum beispiel in frankreich als
touristen kommt er von dort aus illegal
nach deutschland so dass deutschland gar
nicht weiß woher kommt
[Musik]
besonders in den u-bahnhöfen der linie
u7 u8 und u9 werden harte drogen gekauft
und konsumiert
spritzen liegendem gleisbett
sprits wunden entzünden sich das elend
ist extrem
wie eine schar von verlorenen trotten
die abhängigen zu ihrem dealer
sobald die bvg sicherheitsleute weg sind
verteilt dieser am u bahnhof moritzplatz
heroin kugeln die er aus dem mund holt
an einer stelle an der keine
überwachungskamera ihn stört
berliner sind entsetzt denn behörden
geben sich machtlos wenn zu jeder
tageszeit mitten in den gewölben heroin
geraucht und gespritzt wird harte drogen
und aldi nebenerscheinung also
kriminalität
trotze
sogar scheiße
das hat nix in der u-bahn zu suchen und
in diesem land station ist seit monaten
hat sich seine söhne john key community
eingenistet
ich verlange nichts von der welt nicht
von dem senator dass die kinderarmut hat
so aus der welt geschaffen wird ich
verlange dass man als otto normalbürger
benutzen darf
wir durften verdeckte ermittler bei
ihrer arbeit in den bahnhöfen begleiten
sie führen einen schweren kampf auf
weiter flur
alles klar
einem u bahn einsteigt ist ja sowieso
egal wer da so weiter hat so auffällig
hin und her passiert dann wäre ein
kandidat
die beamten führen den jungen mann kurz
bevor sie bei ihm waren sahen sie wie er
etwas herunter schluckte
[Musik]
eine abfrage ergibt dass gegen den
jungen mann bereits wegen drogenhandels
ermittelt wird er bekommt einen
platzverweis der junge mann weiß aus
gesundheitlichen gründen darf die
polizei ihn weder brad noch abführmittel
geben die mit heroin gefüllten
plastikkugeln die er heruntergeschluckt
hat könnten dabei platzen und das kann
tödlich enden
aus dem zahlungsverkehr über solche
gespräche direkt aus japan afrika
da gab es nicht der 260 stimmen
elfter
und wohl gegessen
schwerpunkt wird
ferner 8
für dich
jetzt noch nicht
da erst mal was nämlich recht auf
seine direkten weg nach oben
zu stehen
ein ermittler erklärt wie herausfordernd
seine arbeit ist
gehen sie davon aus dass es passt er
geschluckt hat kann durchaus passieren
dadurch dass die händler die sachen halt
und tragen das kügelchen haben wir
relativ wenig chancen da tatsächlich
dann die kurve zu kriegen dann müssen
wir jetzt wieder von hinten dran dann
ist das ein griff zum hals der dann auch
unter den gesichtspunkten der
verhältnismäßigkeit auch nicht unbedingt
immer das beste mittel ist gerade wenn
man keinen konkreten beweis dafür hat
wenn man ihn vorher beim handel gesehen
hat wäre das natürlich eine maßnahmen
aber dadurch dass er jetzt erst mal
verdächtig war ist das ist das nicht
genug
aber wer steckt hinter dem handel
seit 30 jahren heroinabhängig
erzählt was er mitbekommen hat
die araber
an und stellen ihnen abhängig und die
machen ebenso wenn die panarabische
wurden dann stellen sie ihre bruder da
drei vier tage zeigen sie die hände dann
sind die dran so und wenn die dann
öfters erwischt wurden dann kommen die
anderen landet ist das ist ein klaren
bei den sony machen dazu
carolin diel also meistens die sonne
17.16
noch wie junger mensch manchmal sind die
auch erst 13 oder so beide wollen gerne
einfach nur nach hause schicken oder so
olaf schramm leiter des drogen des
senats vom landeskriminalamt hat 80
mitarbeiter um den drogenhandel zu
bekämpfen
natürlich die haupttäter wurden im
organisierten ebene die können wir die
attraktivität zu rechnen es sind immer
wieder die gleichen auffallenden
personengruppen die hier nach scheidung
treten die herausforderung sind sie bloß
wenn wir den verkäufern in der
öffentlichkeit
identifizieren können festnehmen können
dann haben wir zu 99 9 prozent personen
vor uns sie keine aussagen machen das
heißt wir kommen auf dieser
mit dieser ermittlungsmethode nicht
weiter wenn es um die hintermänner geht
das heißt wir müssen sie aufwendig
verdeckte maßnahmen fahren um dann
vielleicht mal punktuell auch an die
strukturen dahinter heran zu kommen das
ist das große problem wir kommen also
auch nicht dahinter wo die gelder
letztendlich bleiben
wenn es sich um täter handelt die
bestimmten clanstrukturen zuzuordnen
sind dann wissen wir allerdings generell
aus der problematik film hätte dass
solche legalen live oftmals in
immobilien investiert werden und dass
auch hier in unserer stadt
nach berichten über das drogen elend an
der schönleinstraße meldete sich ein
mann bei uns der selbst jahrelang im
drogenhandel tätig war er packte aus
der heroinhandel in den u-bahnhöfen
liegt laut ihm zu großen teilen den
händen einer großfamilie aus dem libanon
familie
nds haben laut ihm 1200 mitglieder in
deutschland die meisten leben in berlin
weil er um sein leben fürchtet möchte
unser informant unerkannt bleiben und
würde als zeuge vor gericht nicht gegen
die hintermänner aussagen
ich bin einer der mit der familie die
das macht gearbeitet hat aber ich wurde
erwischt und habe damit aufgehört es war
eine schlimme arbeit der junge den die
polizei da festgenommen hat ist einer
von der familie sein bruder hatte eine
autovermietung in neukölln da wird das
geld gewaschen
die familie ist in den 90ern nach
deutschland gekommen hat angefangen
drogen zu verkaufen
die machen pro dealer täglich 2.000
3.000 bis zu 5000 euro ende des monats
wird das geld in den libanon geschickt
mit hilfe eines libanesen der auch ein
großer autohändler ist er überweist
illegalen libanon er bekommt pro 1000
euro je 35 euro dafür ohne dass der
staat weiß wieviel es ist und wo es
herkommt es wird damit im libanon viel
land gekauft und häuser werden gebaut in
deutschland werden mit dem geld
autovermietungen zeitungsläden und
autohändler mit großen summe finanziert
unser informant arbeitete als kugel
macher so nennen die szene jene die das
heroin in mülltüten plastik verpacken er
erklärte uns wie das material gestreckt
wird und zeigt mit kaffee weißer wie die
u-bahn dealer mit gefalteten u bahn
tickets die kugel portionieren
meistens laufe das so einer kaufe
vielleicht 250 gramm heroin mische das
mit 250 gramm manitu einem medizinischen
pulver das sei dann etwa 17.500 euro
wert die kugeln werden dann meist in
parks nahe den u-bahnhöfen versteckt
orte die die dealer schon kennen damit
man sie ihn nicht extra am telefon
beschreiben muss
sie verpacken die ware mit folie damit
polizeihunde nicht anschlagen aber die
polizei habe so unser informant sowieso
keine lust nachts in parks mit hunden
nach drogen zu suchen dabei könnten
beamte mit hunden alleine im park am
moritzplatz täglich um die 200 bis 300
gramm holen sagte er
den straßenverkauf übernehmen laut
meistens minderjährige die aus dem
libanon geholt werden cousins oder
brüder von welchen die aus dem direkten
verkauf ausgestiegen sind hauptsache von
der familie damit sie wenn sie erwischt
werden nicht einfach den chef ausliefern
der ja gleichzeitig ein großer bruder
oder onkel ist
laut haben die dealer ihre arbeitszeiten
mittlerweile sehr früh gelegt
von 4 uhr 30 bis 10 uhr machen die 2000
bis 3000 euro manchmal gehen sie noch
abends aber hauptsächlich wenn die
polizei nicht so viel unterwegs ist
morgens früh in der u-bahnlinie früher
runter und früh wieder raus von der u
bahn das ist die devise
diese kleinen arbeiter bekommen täglich
150 euro als lohn für die vier stunden
wer älter wird und heiraten will wird
dann am verkauf beteiligt damit wird
dann im libanon ein haus gebaut
das asylrecht wird ausgenutzt er kommt
mit leeren händen versteckt sein ausweis
seine dokumente und sagte seit
palästinenser er sagte einen falschen
namen ein falsches alter einen falschen
vaternahm einreichen unternahmen alles
falsch zu bekommen aufenthaltsrecht in
deutschland und sozial sie werden
unterstützt anstatt dass sie bestraft
werden ich sehe immer noch mit meinen
augen dass wir ein gutes leben zu führen
hätten sie nichts
[Musik]